no one really surprises me ever
hopefully you will be surprised
hopefully he did a good job
we actually met on a cooking show you
were washing dishes with me when you
first talked to me I saw her on a video
I hit her up on social media and then I
got freaked out cuz I was like who is
this creep you were getting hit on by
some like weird guy and you said like
just just pretend like we're talking or
whatever I was like I had a feeling that
I was gonna marry this person I made him
fly to LA to meet me in person our
second date actually I knew that she was
the one yeah baby grossly sweet he went
back to New York and we liked each other
so we decided that every single month we
would fly to each other or fly to a new
destination and we went on a trip every
month for 16 months and now we're
engaged
I had gone a really long time just
looking for someone to be my partner
with and go on adventures and travel and
do crazy things and then found me Oh see
now you're gonna make me fry well I
guess it's my turn to leave the set we
are super excited to do an engagement
photo shoot bye I can't wait you've
always wanted to go to Italy we will but
I figured for the time being I can
create it and make it for her proposal
was a surprise he does little gifts at
home all the time I wouldn't put it past
a for you guys to marry us right now
Travel is so important our relationship
I'm gonna build a map of the United
States of America I don't know what's
going on I'm excited and nervous but I
have no idea
I started in New York I flew across the
country for Vanita in LA and then we
drove through a place called Vinita
Oklahoma so we're just laying down a
bunch of mulch and actually even got an
old wheel we're gonna be stomping on
grapes and enjoying the scenery alright
I think it's time to go get her this is
looking good I just want to know so I'm
excited let's do it I'm not gonna push
you off a cliff all right stop right
here tada
oh my gosh this is so cool it's out of
the box and I think it's like cute and
different love it yeah
your makeup smells open up your eyes now
[Music]
[Music]
crushing you're taken like each
individual grape between your toes right
today was super exciting I got surprised
actually I was 100% surprised these
photos were incredible I'm excited to
share these pictures with everyone I'm
so excited to see our pictures no I'm
actually kind of nervous a little bit
just to see how they turned out oh you
feel like you're in Italy like it's just
gorgeous such a wonderful memory all
right I love it it's so original and
it's us I want to show this to everyone
thank you so much this was really
special
[Music]